l'organisation altermondialiste attac
pour association pour la taxation des
transactions financières et pour
l'action citoyenne est présente dans 38
pays à travers le monde et en france
depuis 1998 à l'origine l'objectif était
d'obtenir une taxation sur les
mouvements de capitaux aujourd'hui elle
concentre ses efforts cette association
sur la sensibilisation des politiques
économiques respectueuses des aspects
sociaux et environnementaux je reçois
l'un des représentants d'attac dans le
département des yvelines claude
kinésique bonsoir merci d'être passé sur
ce plateau vous proposer plusieurs
rendez vous jusqu'au mois de juin ça a
commencé au mois d'octobre d'une
université populaire avec le prochain
rendez vous le 17 janvier à l encours au
prisme le thème vive la cotisation
sociale pour assurer un salaire avis à
tous pourquoi ce thème effectivement
parce que ce thème rentrer dans un des
quatre thèmes de cette université
populaire qui est penser le futur et
d'en penser le futur nous avons deux de
deux conférences la première qui est
celle de vendredi de du 17 prochain
alors avec bernard friot et cette
conférence sera centré sur le salaire
universel à savoir que à partir du
mécanisme de la cotisation sociale tel
qu'il est fait que nous pour la sécurité
sociale les tendres pour obtenir un
salaire universel versable à tout le
monde à partir de 18 ans la deuxième
conférence sur ce thème là c'est demain
comment je mange son pétrole donc là on
est vers le futur et on essayera de
regarder un peu comment on peut vivre
sans pétrole quel est l'objectif de
cette université populaire que vous avez
décidé de mettre en place alors
l'objectif de cette université c'est de
permettre à tout le monde d'acquérir les
savoirs dont les domaines politiques
sociaux et historiques un peu pour
comprendre le fonctionnement de la
société
un des deuxième objectif c'est de
permettre vraiment à tout le monde
d'accéder à ces savoirs sans ce qu'on
appelle prérequis à dire on n'est pas
obligé d'être diplômé ou d'avoir un
master en économie pour suivre les
progrès que nous en nombre c'est ouvert
au plus grand et tout à fait et donc
cette université se déroule sur toute
l'année 2012 2013 un réseau d'une fois
par mois et sur deux communes la commune
de poissy sur la commune de poisy
l'année là ça va commencer il ya elle
encourt également des prismes voilà
plusieurs thématiques sont abordées 1
jusqu'au mois de juin je regardais le
dépliant par exemple la gratuité des
transports en commun alors la gratuité
des transports en commun ce 14 février
sociaux et qui aura lieu le 14 février
et elle s'inscrit dans le thème des
expérimentations donc on va inviter
fallon cette session sera prise en
charge par la présidente de la
communauté d'agglomération des pays
d'aubagne
madame giovanelli qui sera là et qui va
nous expliquer cette expérimentation
enfin plus qu'une expérimentation c'est
une mise en place des transports
gratuits sur le pays d'aubagne et qui
fonctionne très très bien qu'ils donnent
des résultats très positifs alors à
l'occasion de cette rencontre nous
allons inviter bien sûr monsieur cas
d'albert et le responsable des
transports delà de la ligne maginot et
de la communauté d'agglomération de
saint quentin ça sera un rendez vous
donc le 14 février à celui du 17 janvier
aussi autour des de ses cotisations
sociales et puis on va revenir un petit
peu en arrière le lancement de cette
université populaire qui s'est fait
autour de à quoi servent les banques
j'aimerais vous revenez sur les
conclusions peut-être de ce rendez-vous
j'étais 18 octobre
où l'analyse peut être de la façon dont
ça s'est passé alors il ya eu à peu près
90 personnes qui sont venues beaucoup
d'étudiants ont été surpris beaucoup
d'étudiants et le professeur de saint
quentin en yvelines qui a appris en
charge cette session
avait bien sûr comme comme objectif de
faire un cours accessibles pour tous et
il est parti d'un exemple il a dit ben
voila j'ai une voiture qui tombe en
panne je veux acheter une nouvelle
voiture je vais voir mon banquier pour
avoir un crédit de 5000 euros donc il
est parti de cet exemple là et il a
expliqué comment le banquier fait pour
avoir 5000 euros ou des skis le bon qui
va trouver l'argent c'est quoi une dette
etc et les gens étaient très très
satisfait de la façon dont ça s'est
passé et j'en veux pour exemple la
réflexion au cours du débat qui a lu
après au niveau des questions une dame
m'a dit mais c'est la première fois que
je comprend quelque chose pourquoi
est-ce qu'on nous l'expliquent pas comme
ça mais l'objectif d' attaque est aussi
de faire passer un message de changer la
société c'est toujours d'actualité pour
l'association tout à fait oui et ses
touches et le bon c'est vraiment un
objectif à très long terme mais
d'essayer de changer la société avec une
première phase qui est une phase de type
éducation expliquer expliquer le mieux
possible le monde dans lequel on vit et
une deuxième phase qui est allé vers des
actions des expérimentations c'est ce
qu'ont fait aussi là en faisant des des
cours avec bleu
les transports gratuits par exemple ou
les monnaies locales qui va avoir lieu
au mois de juin si les prises de
positions à travers ces différents
rendez vous tout ce qu'on fait les
thèmes sont pas choisis de matinée de
manière anonyme et on imagine bien
fréquentation plutôt bonne 90 personnes
vous le disais sur le premier rendez
vous à l encours ouvrir en octobre ça
s'est confirmé par la suite oui sur le
deuxième qui était relatif aux
structures familiales et l'impact des
structures familiales sur la société
dont le professeur aussi la de saint
quentin en yvelines parce que cette
université mélange à la fois les
professeurs de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
et des conférenciers de type d'acier nos
internationaux et donc le professeur de
saint quentin en yvelines a fait un
exposé à partir des travaux de
d'emmanuel todd
emmanuel todd qui a trouvé ces travaux
très très intéressant est à féliciter
professeurs pour à la fois la justesse
et la quantité de travail fourni pour
essayer de le démocratiser ces travaux
les rendre accessibles au plus grand
nombre et là aussi 90 personnes ou 95
personnes
présentes à cette session et la
prochaine à qui elles viennent elles ou
à chaque fois en fonction des thèmes
sabots il ya un grand un gros lot de
personnes fidèles et nous sommes assez
surpris il y a beaucoup de gens que nous
avons pas vu sur le circuit traditionnel
dire est content quand tu attaques
organise des conférences on a à peu près
les mêmes types de gens qui viennent et
là il ya des gens nouveaux qui viennent
aider je puisse la toucher un autre
public tout à fait qu'ils découvrent le
travail mené par interac universités
populaires du département des yvelines
mené par attac sud et attaque nord par
les deux groupements dans le département
quels sont les autres actions peut-être
pour conclure d'attac prévu pour les
prochains mois en dehors de l'université
populaire qui va se poursuivre jusqu'à
la fin du mois de juin un programme
complet sur le site qui s'est affiché ce
sera l on courait après si on rappelle
donc en dehors de ces rendez-vous ont
dur de ce rendez vous il n'ya pas deux
il ya uniquement les actions faites donc
à de l'université populaire et bien sûr
à partir du mois de mars la préparation
de l'université populaire de l'an
prochain en 2013 2014 ou là nous allons
aller peut-être un peu plus dans le
domaine des actions savoir expérimenté
des ateliers faire un peu de tp si l'on
peut dire voilà juste un tout petit mot
si je peux me permettre sur le
partenariat nous avons donc cet univers
c'est fait se fait en partenariat avec
deux librairies la librairie le pavé ici
à ça quand on est la librairie de la
réserve amant et de radio alors radio
marmite qui est la radio locale bazar ra
local mais qui enregistre les sessions
et donc on peut réécouter les émissions
sur le podcast de cette radio et la
radio bords de seine et bien sûr on fait
ça en partenariat avec le prisme qui
nous aide énormément grâce à des
spectacles d'elancourt qui vous
accueillera le 17 janvier c'est la
prochaine date à retenir si vous voulez
suivre cette université populaire merci
à claude kiné est revenu sur le plateau
dans un instant la chronique
environnement avec à valérie auribeau il
sera question de consommation avec une
entreprise qui valorise la production
locale auparavant nous allons partir à
la rencontre d'un écrivain belge il
était sur le plateau hier et xavier
deutsch il a écrit le roman 11 qui est
trop trace le parcours d'un groupe de
football amateur qui réussit à faire
chuter l'ac milan c'est de la fiction
mais pourquoi pas sait-on jamais en tout
cas il est actuellement sur saint
quentin en yvelines pour venir à la
rencontre des collégiens des lycéens et
échanger autour de son travail une
volonté de la communauté d'agglomération
saint quentin en yvelines qui souhaitait
valoriser les échanges on regarde au
delà du football on a tous connu à un
moment donné un grand quelqu'un de
puissant qui abusait de sa puissance et
qui se faisait terrassé par un petit je
parle de goliath et de david mais dans
toute l'histoire de l'humanité et dans
nos histoires à nous on a connu des
sales petits chefs qui abusé de leur
autorité et auquel on rêvait de mon
écran aux pieds le pot de terre contre
le pot de fer est une formidable
aventure humaine c'est l'histoire du
roman de xavier deutsch 11 qui relate la
rencontre d'un petit club amateur de
foot contre l' ac milan une histoire qui
va bien au delà du sport et qui a séduit
les jeunes lecteurs venus lundi à la
rencontre de l'auteur au collège hélène
boucher de voisins-le-bretonneux
votre au livre mais ça va plus quand
même l'histoire ça m'intéressait le fait
que celui tous à fond en football pour
arriver à quelque chose en but précis
ce moment intéressé professeurs et
collégiens avaient préparé en amont
l'arrivée du romancier belge question en
main ils sont certes timide les
attentifs et leurs questions vont
parfois au delà du roman mais ce matin
on m'a demandé comment j'avais rencontré
ma femme par quels moyens on m'a demandé
de me prononcer sur la situation
politique en belgique des discussions
ouvertes donc est riche ces rencontres
organisées par les centres de
documentation des collèges et lycées
vont se poursuivre jusqu'à vendredi
après elancourt et voisins le bretonneux
l'auteur devrait investir les
établissements de trappes